the Magnificent Seven is directed by
Antoine Fuqua and stars Denzel
Washington Chris Pratt Vincent D'Onofrio
Ethan Hawke and a ton of other badasses
and is the remake of a remake of a
remake even though it's kind of a
retelling it's a recent thing but it's
something we've seen before that's all
I'm saying master filmmaker Akira
Kurosawa originally made Seven Samurai
and then the Magnificent Seven came out
and now we have another retelling of it
of sorts but it's the same basic story
one small town is being run amok and
taken over by a very evil man played by
Peter Sarsgaard and seven people band
together to help this small town regain
their livelihood and fight back against
these evil people this is a story that's
fairly timeless obviously because it
keeps getting retold there are even tons
of other westerns that have a very
similar feel as this that just weren't
called magnificent 7 as a director I
really like Antoine Fuqua I find him
extremely versatile he can direct a
hard-as-nails drama like training day
then you can do an action film that's
just pure popcorn fun like shooter or
Olympus has fallen or you can make a
fantastic boxing drama like southpaw I
really think he's an uncommonly
versatile director you can do really any
genre and he proves that again by making
a really fun Western with the
Magnificent Seven
I had a total blast with this movie it's
fun from the opening scene to the
closing Denzel Washington do I have to
say anything the man is a friggin master
he is in total command of his craft I
challenge you to take your eyes off
Denzel Washington in this movie he gives
a riveting performance and Chris Pratt
is once again very entertaining and
another extremely likeable role as a
gunslinger
who has a penchant for doing magic
tricks with cards there are a couple
scenes and my wife confirmed this
because I was like was this just me he
gets a little Chris Pratt II just a tad
bit too modern at times with his humor
for this period piece film but really
it's a small nitpick he was really good
I also really liked Ethan Hawke's
character and it was great to see Denzel
and Ethan Hawke back together in a movie
again because they were amazing together
in training day but I really liked him
in this film because he's a very
conflicted character he feels the need
to be there to help these people but he
also has a past with denzel's character
and this pass is catching up to him and
he's starting to feel a little bit
unsure of himself in this position I
thought he was a very fun character and
also a very powerful character the
biggest surprise for me in this movie
was Vincent D'Onofrio I loved him so
much
some people might look at this guy and
think wow that's really over the top
yeah that's what he's best at have you
seen men in black have you seen Full
Metal Jacket
have you seen daredevil the man owns
over the top he's so frickin hilariously
awesome in this movie
his voice is great it's very
high-pitched he's like this very
unassuming person who will just explode
and scalp you Peter Sarsgaard as Bogue
in this film is the man who's taking
over this small town and pillaging and
stealing and killing he is slimy as hell
I mean every shot that he's in it feels
like the frame is dripping with some
kind of goo and if you were concerned
about the film being pg-13 I can assure
you that this is competition for Casino
Royale as the most violent pg-13 I've
ever seen it definitely pulls no punches
yes things get obscured and sometimes
you don't see the blood but it is pretty
brutal but easily the thing that
surprised me the most about this film
was how riveted I was by it it is a
standard popcorn film don't go to this
film expecting a hardcore drama this is
straight-up entertainment and the film
knows that it never tries to be anything
other than that and once you realize
that that's the tone Antoine Fuqua was
going for this film's a ton of fun I
mean it has all the classic Western
things you come to expect except we
haven't seen them in so long and it was
charmingly refreshing to see a film this
old fashioned with classic standoff
duels sequences where characters are
just staring at each other for a really
long time if you've seen the good the
bad and the ugly you've seen the best
standoff in Western history there's
nothing that great in this film but it
is riveting because the performances are
so good and Antoine Fuqua shot this film
very well I mean this is really strong
direction there are shots in this movie
some very beautiful wides of the
countryside there's one shot in
particular where I actually said wow
it's this epic wide shot of bogs army of
horses that happen near the end of the
film that actually really took my breath
away there are two very standout
shootouts in this movie one near the
second act and one of course in the big
finale and both of them were extremely
impressive and tons of fun some might be
upset that it's not as serious minded as
films like Seven Samurai but I don't
really see that to be a problem if this
film is successful it could help
revitalize the western genre the problem
is there's just not that much you can do
in the western genre that hasn't been
done already with films like open range
the most recent django unchained which
this film is nowhere near as good as
that this doesn't have that level of
dialogue or that level of intensity as a
pg-13 action adventure film starring
Denzel Washington Chris Pratt and a bevy
of incredible actors directed by Antoine
Fuqua this film is as good as it could
have been and it actually really
surprised me I had a great time with the
Magnificent Seven and I'm gonna give it
an a-minus because this film knew
exactly what it wanted to be and it
filled itself with a cast that could do
that that could bring that in a director
who understands how to make this
extremely fun to watch and it blew me
away guys thank you so much as always
for watching and thank you to loot crate
for sponsoring my videos if you go to
the link I've left in the description
below and sign up before the 19th of
this month you can get 10% off when you
use the coupon code stuckman for their
September crate of goodies and it's all
about speed there's stuff from CW's the
flash gone in 60 seconds a lot of really
cool stuff in that crate so definitely
check out the link I left in the
description below and use the coupon
code stuckman for 10% off you guys are
the best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]